[Musique]
josée legault michel ces objets jonathan
trudeau bonsoir bonsoir oui un jour
vient du second de ce que fait l'objet
je vous demanderai à la fin de vos
impressions de cette de ce premier tiers
sur la campagne mais c'est un peu normal
que les que c'est pas bouger tant que ça
après une dizaine de jours
monsieur legault aujourd'hui sur
l'immigration en at-il trop dit est-ce
que c'était tellement confus que chacun
peut y percevoir des choses je vais
d'abord mesdames et messieurs vous faire
réentendre la déclaration puis je
demande la ville mais panélistes après
vous voyez être menacée pas être défi
les québécois sont les québécois sont
pacifiques y aime pas la chicane il aime
pas les extrémistes
y aime pas la violence
donc il faut s'assurer qu'on garde comme
c'est le cas actuellement
alors
d'associer davantage
d'immigrants a potentiellement climat de
violence à ce que c'est habile comment
vous avez vu ce jour j'ai le goût de
dire que c'est mal habile système c'est
presque un euphémisme
je pense qu'on peut voir demain si
monsieur legault récidive ou pas mais
j'ai comme l'impression que don
est ce qui s'est mal exprimé
est-ce que c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'il voulait dire parce que bon c'est
évident que pour pour n'importe quel
chef de parti encore plus pour un
premier ministre sortant de de sembler
faire un amalgame entre la chicane la
violence l'extrémisme et l'immigration
ou des sous plus élevé des taux plus
élevés des migrations tout et ça ça ne
tient pas debout on pourrait donner
plusieurs exemples bon à notre
connaissance la personne qui rentrait
dans la mosquée de québec et que tu es 6
ce résidant de québec parce qu'ils
étaient musulmans s'étaient pas une
immigrante donc on espère que c'était
une erreur si on revient que c'est un
mot qu'on a beaucoup trop utilisé n'est
pas que l'amalgamé là il ya
effectivement l'amalgamme qu'on ne
comprend peut-être pas très bien mais
chassez auger
l'important c'est ce qui va se passer
demain s'il revient avec ça vous avouer
c'est ce que je dis est vrai m
immigration et violences dans la même
phase on contacte le passage côté
quelque part
monsieur le mot peut l'avoir fait de
façon très très intentionnelle ou pas
est stationné du tout c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'il ya des filles de mai mais la
réalité c'est que quand on fait ça on en
voit une espèce de messages
l'immigration peut dire violence
je pense que le québec voulait envoyer
mais c'est à lui de les clarifier
jonathan
on a souvent dit que françois legault
avait la capacité d'être son pire ennemi
le démontrer encore une fois aujourd'hui
parce que c'était je vais vous dire au
mieux malhabile et au pays très divisé
voire dangereux moi je n'aime pas
entendre je comprends que c'est le chef
de quoi son avenir québec mais il a
encore ses habits de premier ministre
j'aime pas du tout entendre le premier
ministre dire ce genre de discours la
très très très divisif tecsys me faire
un amalgame avec immigration
violence respect extrémisme c'est
totalement déplacé vous vous demandiez
ce qu'il veut il va réitérer demain fait
quelques vérifications il faut pas
s'attendre à ce que françois legault
retombe sur ce terrain là demain on dit
que ils vont rappeler que l'immigration
est une richesse mais il a laissé une
goutte de sang dans un océan infestée de
requins dire parce que évidemment les
autres partis politiques qui se cherche
une faiblesse chercham et françois
legault sur la défense et ils vont
exploiter cette file et avec raison
parce que la nasa n'avait pas sa place
comme propos ok donc
josé mais oui comme jeux pc ça comme je
disais tout à l'heure moi je pense qu'il
ne revienne il ne répétera pas cette
phrase bon c'était comme dire si on en
reçoit trop ça va être des ordres plus
vendre de la violence qui va voir s'il y
avait bon très bien qu est ce on parle
de gens qui se sont emmêlés dans leurs
pinceaux le q est-ce avec leur
proposition de taxer les super riches d
fiscale et si on commençait regardé ça
ce matin de vaud émulation qu'on prend
en compte le fonds de retraite si on
prend en compte les lavoirs immobilier
les reér et tout ça ça le cercle est pas
mal plus grand que les super super
riches qu'on a en tête j'en attaqué sa
pensée
pour avoir déjà eu l'opportunité d'être
sur une tour nil sur la caravane
électorale c'est ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de journée atroce pour québec
solidaire est une journée qui est perdue
parce que il avait une proposition
et en laquelle il croyait beaucoup
pensaient faire du millage là dessus
finalement se sont retrouvés sur la
défensive toute la journée ont même dû
improviser apporté certaines
modifications
on a vu moi mon émission de radio je l'
ai vécu des candidats qui ne connaissait
pas tous les tenants et aboutissants de
cette proposition le donc c'est
difficile pour québec solidaire parce
que cette élection là pour eux c'est une
ligue où un test de crédibilité
j'ai envie d'y arriver à le démontrer
comme une opposition officielle en
attente éventuellement même peut-être un
gouvernement en attente et là vous avez
des propositions comme celle qui à la
base semble être intéressant pour des
gens qui disent bon douala on cherche un
peu plus dans les poches des
multimillionnaires mais quand on regarde
à quel point ça ratisse large à quel
point il ya des points d'interrogation
que des lacunes là dedans le test de
crédibilité malheureusement québec
solidaire aujourd'hui le échoue à ce
niveau là on va écouter gabriel nadeau
dubois avant de vous entendre michel et
josiane écoute
à mesure qu'on annoncé hier exemple les
terres agricoles pour ce qui est du
reste des actifs ils sont inclus dans
notre mesure moi j'ai pris les contacts
des différentes fédérations agricoles
pour qu'on discute de la réalité pour le
moment notre engagement et car les
campagnes vont vite c'est des erreurs ça
arrive
[Musique]
des campagnes vont enlever des erreurs
ça arrive michel
où il y avait un petit côté bienvenue la
ligue nationale qui reçoit montre bien
gros coup de coude de la
fête c'est quelque chose de mal ficelé
et
beaucoup beaucoup de jeu dans cette
définition la du millionnaire beaucoup
beaucoup de gens de la classe moyenne
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas
pour ça serait mignon simulcast c'est
vrai qu'à taxe de bienvenue si vous
achetez une maison alors pour faut
relativiser mais c'est le genre de chose
qui est difficile à expliquer et qui
auraient dû justement à des
interprétations comme celle-là pilon des
rangers des taxes orange et du show
c'est une erreur a
été forcé par l'adversaire ce souk si
j'osais et d'ailleurs il a dû reculer
sur les terres agricoles enfin lui dit
que c'était pas reculer parce que
c'était une erreur que ça a été la sava
pas déjà être la clé terres agricoles ne
feront pas partie m6 et le
pardon il ya une fiscalité différente
déjà dans les lois en plus oui alors
josé
non mais c'est ça c'est vraiment c'est
une journée de perdue c'est ça montre
aussi que les autres chefs de parti
n'ont pas l'intention de faire le
moindre cadeau à gmt c'est assez évident
pourtant c'est une idée qui est pas du
tout farfelu on retrouve ça dans
d'autres pays en europe mais il ya eu
deux erreurs fondamentales premièrement
utilisé l'expression super riches comme
le disait michel si lorsqu'on fait
référence à des ja qui sur papier en
tout cas peuvent avoir l'air d'être
millionnaire au singulier mais ne sont
pas vraiment les faits et la deuxième
c'est d'avoir mal préparé cette annonce
là de l'avoir mal expliqué et
quoique pour ce qui est sa base
électorale je pense pas que ça va lui
faire
énormément de temps parce que l'idée de
base elle est bonne
mais si comme le problème c'est que
évidemment québec solidaire cherche
élargit sa base à parce qu'il vise
l'opposition officielle et la dass qui
est à l'extérieur de sa vraie base ça ça
peut faire un petit peu tôt hausse du
taux directeur aujourd'hui de trois
quarts de point ça c'est très réel on le
disait sur le paiement des hypothèques
sur c'est le remède à l'inflation qui
fait mal aux gens qui ont le moins de
revenus qu'en même temps le remède fait
mal aussi à pas mal de monde est ce que
ça ne montre pas je n'attache quand
c'est avec vous que les leviers au
gouvernement son g impôts si nombreux
pour faire face à tout ce oui les envois
de chèques des annonces qu'on a vu en
début de campagne mais n'empêche on est
quand même un peu moins puissant mais
pas loin peut-être là on est dans un
grand paradoxe est assurément parce que
bon c'est pas une surprise cette
nouvelle hausse je trouve les bouchers
les très très grande loge de bien des
gens qui vont avoir un passage difficile
au cours des prochains mois mais reste
que l'essentiel mais je pense que vos
servi aux différents partis politiques à
s'appuyer sur les promesses qui ont déjà
été fait je pense à des êtres plus
ciblées comme québec solidaire comme le
parti québécois ou à des baisses
d'impôts et des chèques comme veut le
faire
la quoi son avenir québec ou encore le
parti libéral du québec mais quand je
parle du grand paradoxe c'est que si la
banque du canada augmente les taux
d'intérêt c'est pour freiner la dépense
pour baisser l'inflation hors lo vous
avez des passes politiques qui disent
ben nous on va vous aider à continuer à
dépenser si vous voulez je sais que
certains vont dire notamment carlos
leitao qui après m'avoir n'est pas
favorable à des baisses d'impôts vos
dires belle à part ce contexte là on a
besoin d'aider les gens pour faire des
dépenses pour des biens essentiels si on
veut mais il reste que yeux quand même
ce paradoxe à savoir bien on vient pu
contrer les efforts de la banque du
canada en faisant ce qu'on m'a pas de la
censure pure
michel c
et d'autre part pour oublier que la
banque a déjà averti quand ils vont se
réunir dans trois mois il faut augmenter
les taux d'intérêt encore oublié ça
parce que c'est une
démarche graduelle mais elles n'ont pas
arrêté cela dit on a eu des années de
tout intérêt extrêmement bon alors vous
savez un taux directeur à 3.75 salaire
beaucoup comparé à ce que c'était
l'année dernière c'est pour beaucoup
historiquement alors il faut il faut
relativiser je je je j'ai acheté ma
première maison des taux d'intérêt à dix
huit mois je m'en souviens c'était
on s'en rend pas à ce niveau la
déflation et de semis bolloc'h donc de
dudu de l'outil très imparfait que celui
que la banque du canada c'est-à-dire de
d'augmenter le taux de 5 ans non
heureusement elle contexte différent
josé
c'est parce que c'est une problématique
tellement large dans les faits éliminés
on a laissé les gens être piégé
littéralement justement par des taux
d'intérêt très bas ce qui a alimenté une
spéculation
frénétique dans l'immobilier mais aussi
sur le prix des loyers donc oui
peut-être qu'à trop pour ça et que ça ça
semble pas énorme mais sur les prix
qu'on a proportionnellement des prix de
maisons et des loyers
proportionnellement aux revenus déjà
savoir faire très mal à plusieurs
personnes et la maintenance qu'on arrive
après avoir encouragé l'endettement
encourager les gens à acheter des
maisons qui étaient beaucoup trop cher
des loyers de louer des logements a
beaucoup trop cher pauvre on remonte les
les tours les taux d'intérêt pour que ça
leur coûte encore plus cher alors
pendant que pour ceux qui ont acheté on
nous prédit que la valeur des propriétés
elle va passer aussi en même temps
occulter c'est la tempête parfaite en
quelque part c'est pour ce que les
baisses d'impôt c'est c'est vraiment un
coup d'épée dans l'obs été responsable
pour l'avenir
ça prend oui des aides ciblées sur les
personnes qui en ont vraiment besoin
mais il faut agir ou si justement sur la
spéculation immobilière la crise du
logement ces terrasses sont ce sont les
prêts problème que beaucoup de gens
vivent
tout à fait françois legault vient de
tweets et je vais vous le montrez je
reviens l'autre sujet parce que ça vient
d'arriver
alors oui il veut mettre fin tout de
suite aujourd'hui l'immigration écrite
il ya quinze secondes est une richesse
pour le québec
l'intégration sera toujours un défi pour
une nation francophone en amérique du
nord je n'ai pas voulu associer
l'immigration à la violence je suis
désolé si mes propos ont porté à
confusion
ma volonté c'est de rassembler donc on
veut corriger le tir tout de suite pour
pas que demain soit pris à répondre un
kart 14 questions là dessus que les
chiffres viennent il veut éteindre ça
tout de suite jonathan
mais je pense c'était la bonne chose à
faire le il n'y a pas que du mal en
médias sociaux ça permet de réagir
rapidement au début on me disait vous le
mentionnez qui tiendrait essentiellement
ses propos de demain je pense que devant
le tollé c'était une bonne chose de
réagir rapidement et j'imagine qu'on
nous dira qu encore une fois les
québécois seront apprécié la capacité de
françois legault à s'excuser lorsqu'il
dépasse les bornes mais j'imagine aussi
que ses opposants vont dire parce que
dans les faits ils n'avaient pas livré
le fond de sa pensée et que les 80
décemment a dit j'ai l'impression qu'on
veut entendre quand même parler encore
demain le hamas mais vous avez raison je
n'attends il il a cette capacité de
pouvoir s'excuse et puis que ça passait
les gens lui disent bon mais c'est bien
là il l'a reconnu michel celle il
reconnu que c'est confus et fallait pas
il a mélangé des concepts dans même
phrase
il fallait le faire à la première
occasion s'excuser ce qu'ils viennent
faire donc bon c'est sûr que les uns des
opposants vont essayer de l'utiliser
encore demain ça fait partie de la joute
politique mais le feu est pas mal
éteints s'il ne fait pas un autre lapsus
ou un autre sous-entendu malheureux dans
la campagne sur le même sujet ce qui
n'est pas complètement impossible
ça devrait aller mais naïve sur ce sous
surveillance sur ce sous pseudo si
j'osais le cycle des campagnes
électorales n'est plus le même là on
voit les nouvelles arrivées et ont réagi
la même journée la
wii jeu écoutez je pense que monsieur
leroux vient de poser le geste qu'il
fallait pause il ils ont trouvé aussi
lui son entourage les bons mots parce
que sa déclaration comme on dit tout à
l'heure c'est un amalgame qui est très
dangereux et on espère que pour les
cieux de la campagne ça servira aussi de
voyages jaune à tout le monde mais comme
citoyenne je
sais pas ce qu'on aurait pu faire dans
les prochains dans les prochains jours
s'ils savaient perdurer mais comme je
disais au début du panel j'étais
persuadé qu'il ne le répèterai pas mais
d'ajouter des excuses c'est donc une
bonne idée ben on va se laisser sur sa
merci beaucoup à vous trois